hi everyone
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy welcome
to our daily live stream for those of
you all who are wondering what this is
you know this is something we started
several months ago as a way to keep us
all connected during times of social
distancing and and just have interesting
guests and have interesting
conversations and take your questions
and today like always I'll be taking
your questions on Facebook or on YouTube
and we have team members who can surface
what y'all are asking we've done a we're
going into a last-minute change to
today's livestream because of all that's
going on in the world we originally had
one of our great team members Marta
who's our VP of engineering scheduled to
join but given what's going on in the
world you know I thought we would be
better to save Marta for a day where you
know there isn't all of this going on
and you know I just want to give my two
cents here for for whatever it's worth
you know a lot of times I I'm very
careful about saying you know Khan
Academy and we it's true we are not a
political organization we as an
organization are not left we are not
right we are just trying to empower as
many people in the world to have access
to an education and I think every now
and then there's an issue that comes up
that frankly transcends politics and I
think that what's going on right now
with obviously what happened to George
Floyd but obviously that's just one in a
string of many incidents where you
really only one side to this and that
there's just some basic human dignity
that isn't being given to two folks and
you know sometimes you can rationalize
that well you know the whole world
there's going to be things that happen
that are unfortunate but you know for
every one of these things that captures
folks attention that gets you know
captured on on someone's cell phone
you've got to imagine that there's
another 100 or another thousand that
don't get the attention and don't get
captured and for every time something
horrible like this happens
someone gets killed or severely injured
you have to imagine that there's another
thousand times that it doesn't quite go
get that far but someone is humiliated
where someone is unjustly imprisoned or
we're just treated in an inhumane way
and this is a real thing this isn't just
something that happens on the news I
remember when I was in in business
school this was back in 2003 one of my
classmates Matt Turner I know he's he's
written about this so he probably
wouldn't mind me mentioning his name
who's african-american he was a section
president he was an Air Force captain he
had gone with me to MIT he was clearly
at Harvard Business School and he was
visiting some friends in Dallas and
while he was visiting he was just
walking on the street and all of a
sudden a police helicopter and cops
policeman show started showing up when
you know and and you know with with guns
out and and he was arrested for for an
hour and and frankly humiliated and it
turns out that the crime that he was a
suspect for was committed by four white
men several miles away and that was the
first time that it was an AHA in my mind
that this is not something that is just
an abstract thing that happens in random
parts of the you know places that are
disconnected they can happen to your
friends they can happen to your family
that can happen to people you care about
and if it happens to someone like Matt
who is you know by any measure as a as
as you know kind of living he's cut you
know the the the aspirational life that
we you know he he's or what we should
aspire to I should say and and has you
know served for our military you know
doing everything right on the credit
if he gets humiliated like that you
could imagine what happens to folks who
have less of a voice less of a platform
less representation so
this is a really huge thing in all of us
at Khan Academy we pride ourselves on
that we want to help level the playing
field we want to make sure that everyone
can empower can can tap into their
potential but if you don't have basic
human dignity if you have to worry about
your own safety just because of the
color of your skin because of the way
you might look I think you know that
just hampers your ability to have an
openness to anything else so being able
to engage in your education or your
career whatever else so anyway you know
I wish there were things that I I knew
of that that I could take more action
other than just speaking out about it
that this is this transcends politics
the only thing that I can right now
imagine that is going to make a
difference is for there to be real
accountability I think you know it's
hard for for anyone to imagine a
situation where where this shouldn't be
held accountable and you know the whole
theory of justice is you might not
capture every crime or you not not be
able to help hold everyone accountable
but if there's at least examples where
people who clearly did wrong are held
accountable it can help create pause and
keep others from from doing things in
the future and obviously it shouldn't
just be about the people who directly
committed it it should be the people who
are also kind of a let some of this
stuff go by for many many years so
anyway I I don't want a you know I don't
want to pretend that I'm you know a
major actor in this but I did just want
to say that this is something that has
you know unfortunately seems like we
hear stories about this every three four
five six months and they're
disappointing but they just keep
building on each other and they're
they're very very unfortunate and you
know just breaks your heart to see it
and it breaks your heart to think about
how many other situations there might be
like this in the US and frankly around
the world where you know there's people
in in groups who for whatever reason
don't have as much voice and you know
people who have more power sometimes
abuse that power
and you know I want to make it very
clear there's many great wonderful
people and law enforcement that the bulk
of people who desire to go into law
enforcement want to do it because they
want to protect society they want to
uphold the values that we all believe in
but there is I think more than just a
few bad apples in that for sure in any
field there might be people who get into
the wrong for the wrong reason but they
should not be allowed to act on it
especially when they have the public's
trust especially when they are armed
especially when they can arrest folks
and and physically you know manipulate
of you know impact folks you have to
have just a much much higher standard of
conduct at a much higher standard of of
what it means to hold other people
accountable and not allow this type of
thing to to go on so anyway I'll get off
on my soapbox this is a bother
you know I'm fortunate I haven't
directly experienced this in my life but
obviously folks close to me have and
when you see some things like this it
really disturbs you but but anyway I'm
happy to look at questions comments you
know and I this is really just kind of
an open minded discussion I'd love ideas
if you know folks might have let's see a
few folks are commenting about my
haircut I thank you I mean on a on a
lighter on a lighter note be part of
that the haircut situation is I was so
excited about the SpaceX launch which I
guess was a silver lining from from from
the weekend that my wife wanted to give
me a haircut and I was in such a hurry I
just took the Clipper from her and I I
did this but anyway thanks for thanks
for that comment I have mixed feelings
about it but that was a that was a
highlight of the weekend to see kind of
what I think is some of the best of
humanity when we work together the cool
things that we could do together and I
hope that I can on the livestream bring
some folks from SpaceX at some point
NASA to talk about that but you know
it's sad that the same society that can
do incredible things like that on the
same level we can't give basic human
dignity to large chunks of our
population let's see other as comments I
mean you know there's you know a lot of
a lot of good questions and you know
I'll just help state it just feels you
know normally I like answering pretty
much any any question that that comes
and and some of these are very
flattering to Khan Academy or to me but
it just feels you know a little bit
beside the point right now you know and
look this this crisis or whatever we're
going through and obviously it's late
layered on top of at least one other
large crisis it's not going to end today
it's not going to end tomorrow you know
we kind of but it is yeah this might be
the the thing that finally makes this a
a major issue that doesn't just get
talked about when there's another cell
phone footage of you know someone being
abused or mistreated or in this case you
know killed for no other reason than
being in the in the in the wrong place
in the wrong time with the wrong person
but but unfortunately we see a little
bit too much about that well you know
this is a question from Facebook related
to what we're seeing a month batterer
bhattacharya as an educator where should
I start teaching my students about
racism you know I don't I don't want to
pretend like I'm an expert at this so I
I can't really give a lot of advice on
it
I would love advice actually from other
folks on what you know if there's ways
that Khan Academy or folks like us could
help we'd love to know but you know I do
have a general view that the more
exposure you have to folks that are not
like yourself and you the more
appreciation that children have or
people of all ages have
that frankly everyone on the planet is
pretty much just you know normal people
trying to get on with their lives and
have basic health basic safety basic
education trying to do right by their
children and you know I've just just
pretty much described almost everyone
then you know hopefully we see a world
where where some of this doesn't doesn't
happen as much you know I I I'm someone
who prides myself in trying you know
being able to empathize and seeing both
sides of an issue or all three sides of
an issue but I only have trouble getting
in the minds of folks who Harbor the
degree of hate or anger irrational I
mean with no uh you know I to be able to
to be able to do these types of things
you know there's there there's no you
know there's there's been incidents
before that have been also atrocious but
there's maybe you know maybe the maybe
there was fear or maybe there was this
or that but that you know this is a
situation where you even if you're
grasping for straws there's no straws to
grasp on and all you can talk think of
it is it's pure hate pure anger and it's
it's hard to it's it's hard to
understand that frankly but but yeah
let's see from Facebook I wish I could
be more helpful
Deena Newman we we talk with our kids
about having conversations with people
we are uncomfortable with and ask
questions and hear stories to change the
narratives we already have in our heads
great so there you go two month us
question Deena has kind of answered it
which is you know we have to be
comfortable in our discomfort and that
might be people that we we've
stereotyped in one way or the other and
it goes both ways you know I think we're
in a time where clearly a lot of
african-american folks
or minority folks might get stereotyped
and are treated unfairly and you know
there's this is a time where a lot of
very good people who work in government
or law enforcement are also you know
probably themselves shaking their heads
and saying you know it's they're
probably less worried about themselves
been saying like what's so unfortunate
that this is happening
because I mean it's just so many layers
obviously the the very act that it
happens and then there's a layer of its
it just breaks down trust and it's and
sometimes it might become harder to have
those conversations that you're
referring to where folks can talk to
people who they might be initially done
comfortable with or who might feel like
they have a different life story or life
path of themselves so if there's if
there is a silver lining is it's that
this is kind of the the straw that
breaks the camel's back that you know
real accountability is going to happen
it's not just in Minneapolis but it's
systemic real accountability and I hope
that the the energy just gets channeled
to the you know more of these
conversations that you're talking about
you know I think the protests are an
important part obviously the peaceful
protests are a very important part of
that I hope they continue and the energy
continues and I hope over time that
energy also gets grows and gets
transferred in to assist systemic change
you know not but I don't have a clear
idea of exactly how all of that plays it
out but that can also be a be a hope
Missy from Facebook al Fink for ideas on
how to talk to white students you could
read raising white kids by Jennifer
Harvey Susie to have these difficult
conversations black lives matter in
school is one model for encouraging
conversations about race in school yeah
thanks for that comment Alfie and I I
don't know about this book so I don't I
can't officially endorse it but yeah I
think it it seems to go into that same
theme of you know just more empathy and
realizing that that you know as I said
earlier everyone's just trying to live
live a decent life and it's really sad
when
you know just it in in you know I tend
to be an American Exceptionalist I tend
to you know I tend to be very proud of
many at least what the country has
attempted to stand for obviously it's
had its issues going back to slavery and
racism and the civil I mean we could we
could go in you know III could say oh
well you know my family came to this
country after all of that happened but
I'm a beneficiary of this country and
that means I'm also a beneficiary of its
history and its history is not perfect
by any stretch of the imagination and so
I think any of us even even those of us
who are immigrants or who are family
whose families immigrated here but we
are able to benefit from this country
which I do love should also should feel
should reflect on our history and of the
country obviously reflect on the history
of where maybe your roots are as well
but but also feel responsibility to
think about how to how to you know how
to how to change things because a lot of
that history clearly has still it has
still a lot of probably more than we
recognize there's there's a lot of stuff
going on that that's still there so
let's see other things so so such and
pilote is this actually the same session
that I went to business school with well
if it is well either way good to see you
such an if it's such an I know it all
starts at home how does one ensure we're
able to teach our kids to walk around
someone else's shoes empathy and
kindness should be our focus at home in
our schools yeah couldn't couldn't agree
more whether you're the such in that I
know or a new such in I think here this
I don't know how many such and pilote
store in the world it's great to see
here from you such and but yeah
completely agree and I think it is you
know it's intriguing I've talked to
other nonprofits that have been very
focused on empathy and empathy projects
and I've theorized hey wouldn't it be
cool if there's ways to you know get in
the cloud and volunteer and teach kids
who are on the you know quote the other
side of the railroad tracks from
yourself or other side of the
country or in a country that your
country is that odds with but you
realize that the people there are still
people yeah I agree I think that's
that's how empathy that's how empathy
happens
let's see mahir i from facebook says no
one is born with hatred it's certain
parts of our society that inculcate such
a thing and school is the only place
where we can remove this yeah I agree I
agree and you know and I think you know
well yeah I'm not an expert at any of
this I'm just kind of thinking live
about about this and you know for
whatever it's it's it's worth so yeah
there's a lot of other questions about
Khan Academy and and normally I would
really enjoy answering all of these
questions but given given what's what's
going on in the world I might take a
pass at least for today I mean I don't I
don't want I don't want us to I don't
want us to kind of stay mired and in
this you know forever but I also don't
want to lose the energy there and kind
of just say oh this was unfortunate and
then move on and then life is normal
again and then six months later it
happens again and then everyone gets
says oh this is unfortunate how horrible
and then life gets normal and then six
months later it happens again which is
unfortunately been the pattern for the
last 20 or so years so so yeah that's
that's I'll just maybe leave it at that
for today cuz you know I mean there's a
lot of there's a lot of quite good good
questions here about Khan Academy and
education and all of that but I think
for for for today's episode of the live
stream we'll just make it a little bit
of this like you know this is just a
moment for all of us to pause all of us
to think about you know what kind of a
society we want to be what kind of a
country we want to be you know how how
does the justice system work how do we
hold folks accountable and yeah and and
how do we not you know on you know paint
paint folks with a with a broad brush
and treat everyone with with dignity and
I'll just leave it at that leave it at
that you know we're gonna have some
interesting guests for the next couple
of days
the CEO of Novartis the mayor of San
Jose I am going to ask them a few
questions about things like this I think
they both have an interesting viewpoint
and then we'll will kind of continue and
talk about other things as well like
things like like education etc but
obviously there there's a lot of energy
as there should be around what happened
to George Floyd you know I have to say
there's another dimension of this that
like you know he he's roughly my age and
you know so there's something about that
that you build even a little bit more
empathy where you say wow you know what
what if that was me what if it's my
children who are you know because of
some act of Cruelty or whatever and so
anyway I don't know just stream of
thought consciousness for me my
apologies for not being my my chipper
self but yeah you know this this is this
is hopefully hopefully this this pain
leads to some growth for us as as as a
society and and you know not just in the
US but but around the world and you know
it's it's all about and it's not just
about pointing fingers it's about
looking at ourselves you know this is
this happens you know in the US we talk
about red states and blue states and we
can easily say oh this is happening
because people on that side of the
politics did this or didn't do that and
on this side we're better but you know
I've seen aspects of this happen from
you know people who vote either way you
know my you know I had actually another
friend I won't use her name because I
don't think she's publicly talked about
this but this was actually again in
Business School she was a Harvard
student and she was going into her own
apartment in Harvard Square and the
police accosted her and arrested her for
for for thinking that she was
burglarizing her own apartment
and she was she was african-american and
so you know it's it's these aren't
random and and these are just kind of
the things that you know i-i've happened
to see in my own lifetime directly and
obviously you hear the things on the
news so yeah let's just all collectively
think about how we can how we can you
know not just feel upset about it
and not just talk about it but that the
energy continues beyond the moment and
it leads to real change and real
accountability at a systemic level so
with that I'll let everyone go but you
know thanks for joining this live stream
and you know my apologies for Marta we
did the last-minute change and I hope to
have Mardon again I think many of y'all
will enjoy talking to her and we'll
continue this conversation and obviously
it's connected to education and
empowerment which is where Khan Academy
is is focused on but thanks everyone for
joining and let's just hope pray
meditate whatever you like to do that
that we can we can find that some good
comes out of what obviously is a very
unfortunate series of situations and
circumstances talk to y'all later
you